the summerlin parade is back in person
in 2020 the parade was virtual with the
online broadcast even
receiving an emmy nomination our sherry
swank's
brian loftis will host once again along
with jc fernandez and mercedes martinez
and speaking
of mercedes she joins us now with the
preview
it is america's birthday party parade
and it is back in person this year happy
fourth of july
almost everyone it is so great to be
back in person celebrating i have tommy
perello here
from the summerlin council and the
parade is back tell us about it we are
so excited to be able to put this on for
the community we had a shorter period of
time
but we were able to get the support we
needed from our
the community our sponsors and we're
able to put together a very energetic 30
minute parades
a little smaller route than previous
still starts in the same location but
it's not going to be quite as long this
time
let's talk about that location the
parade begins at the corner of hill
point road and hill center drive
and it is a little shorter you
definitely want to get here early parade
starts at 9
and also what day is the parade
it is on july 3rd since the 4th falls on
sunday we're happy to celebrate with you
on the third and then you can be with
your families on the floor
yes it's a great day to extend that
fourth of july celebration and
it's such a fun event for everyone we
look so forward to seeing you guys
so july third nine pm up in summerlin
really quick
tell us about some of the floats what do
we have here birthday cakes everywhere
parker yes it's a party theme we have
hats we have cakes we're gonna have a
lot of live celebrations with great
music
uh just a really spirited forward-moving
30-minute parade that's just a mobile
show
for everyone to enjoy and it's a party
in the usa we'll see you there